il mio ufficio qui a reggio emilia è un
ufficio pieno di computer molto potenti
di nuvoloni di cloud e di lavagna
scarabocchiate da algoritmi e da modelli
matematici perché facciamo progetti
complessi che riguardano appunto analisi
di dati complesse in questo ufficio
esiste una piccola cucina che
egoisticamente io ho voluto perché io
vengo da modena e nella pausa pranzo non
posso tornare a casa a mangiare con me
rimangono i colleghi che invece
potrebbero tornare a casa a pranzo ma ci
piace condividere questo momento dove ci
facciamo due chiacchiere
la nostra tavola è apparecchiata in un
modo strano cioè della pasta
dell'insalata ci sono dei nachos ci sono
c'è zurek c'è del riso cucinato con
curry e curcuma del pollo di d g
questo perché noi siamo di varie
nazionalità e alcuni di noi sono
italiani alcuni sono italiani che
rientrati in italia dopo dei dieci di
all'estero e poi ci sono persone invece
due ragazzi indiani 1 del camerun una
persona polacca e uno messicano
noi non siamo diversi solo per
nazionalità siamo diversi per età
andiamo dai 25 anni ai 49 anni siamo
uomini e donne anche se in questo
settore le donne sono poche ne vorremmo
molti di più
siamo diversi per titolo di studio le
lauree sono diverse c'è chi è laureato
in fisica chi in statistica chi in
ingegneria informatica in psicologia a
chi in comunicazione e marketing che
l'economia se siamo molto diversi tra di
noi alcuni complici di altri senza psd è
la lingua che noi utilizziamo in questo
pranzo è in parte l'italiano in parte
l'inglese che cosa ci accomuna il fatto
che c'è chi vuole perfezionare
l'italiano e chi perfezione all'inglese
tutti abbiamo come obiettivo quello di
migliorare la nostra pronuncia perché
purtroppo è la cosa più difficile e
quando è più faticoso per noi poi
abbiamo le altre lingue e dei loro paesi
di origine
oppure degli anni che hanno trascorso
all'estero per i loro piedi
di che cosa parliamo essendo consigli
diversi parliamo del prossimo campionato
mondiale di cricket a londra nel 2019
parliamo di calcio e di lavatrici perché
alcuni di loro non hanno la più pallida
idea di come si prepara una lavatrice
parliamo di cibo ovviamente perché
comunque è un argomento sempre
importante io ho scoperto che il platano
oltre a essere un albero da fusto è
anche un frutto e che si può mangiare ho
scoperto che il riso basmati chi in
india estremamente costoso e che per
esempio non esiste il melograno così
come non sono carciofi o altri altre
altri frutti o altre verdure
parliamo dei miei figli adolescenti
per loro che per diversi di loro che i
figli non ce li hanno delle liti delle
battaglie delle lotte che io faccio con
loro chiaramente loro tifano per i miei
figli e non per me però ci sta nel gioco
delle cose poi arrivano i temi the money
i demoni sulla religione la cultura
la storia le tradizioni che sono
comunque estremamente interessanti
quello che abbiamo scoperto è che nel
mondo i cognomi non vengono attribuiti
in base al cognome del padre ma ci sono
criteri che possono essere diversi per
esempio il nome del villaggio dal quale
si proviene è vero che in queste
occasioni spesso tutti i giovani siamo
molto diversi tra di noi ma un piatto di
pasta o un pollo dg ci mette d'accordo
tutti quindi ci sono i giorni in cui
siamo tutti diversi ma anche tutti
uguali
in realtà non ci accomuna solo questo a
nessuno di noi piace lavare i piatti
dopo questa è un'altra cosa che ci
accomuna
dopo il pranzo giocava biliardino che
gioca con me sa che ha un'altissima
probabilità di perdere ma in questo caso
pazienza dopo chiaramente torniamo a
lavorare e anche in questo caso siamo
tutti uguali e tutti diversi
siamo tutti uguali perché abbiamo un
unico obiettivo il successo aziendale e
il successo dei nostri progetti però
contribuiamo tutti in modo diverso
perché comunque abbiamo età diverse
esperienze diverse
abbiamo ruoli diversi in azienda abbiamo
competenze diverse e un'indole diversa e
quindi appunto abbiamo un unico progetto
ma che in realtà si declina in tanti
modi
che cosa
che cosa facciamo insieme insieme
realizziamo questi progetti
particolarmente ambiziosi di innovazione
tecnologica e in un mercato molto
difficile che facciamo fatica a
penetrare e quindi ci dedichiamo con
grande passione a questo grande tema
cerchiamo di semplificare la complessità
con grande tenacia e grande
determinazione
poi facciamo insieme per esempio abbiamo
pianto insieme perché sfortunatamente
gli dà che è la figlia del mio socio e
quest'anno ci ha lasciati abbiamo dovuto
salutarla
a seguito di una lunga malattia che ha
colpito tanti di noi è però festeggiamo
anche rinnovo di un permesso di
soggiorno perché comunque questo regala
loro la libertà di rimanere in italia la
libertà di tornare a casa la libertà di
viaggiare per per turismo e poi
viaggiando nel mondo viaggiamo nel mondo
per convegni per eventi per per vendere
perché comunque il nostro obiettivo è
quello di vendere i nostri progetti ai
nostri prodotti
la strategia tante volte mi viene
chiesto che strategia abbiamo applicato
per arrivare ad essere un'azienda
multiculturale non abbiamo applicato
nessuna strategia è praticamente noi
molto concretamente abbiamo pubblicato
degli annunci di lavoro tra i candidati
che hanno risposto questi annunci di
lavoro
noi abbiamo selezionato le persone più
competenti e più vicini a noi come
valori personali e professionali e non
abbiamo badato a il colore della pelle o
al paese di provenienza abbiamo scelto
le persone che ritenevamo appropriate
per quel ruolo aziendale quindi non
abbiamo applicato nessuna strategia
abbiamo lasciato che gli eventi
fruissero come dovevano fluire senza
curarci del loro colore della pelle
oppure appunto di altre cose nemmeno la
lingua nel senso che una delle persone
che lavora
noi parla pochissimo italiano parla
prevalentemente inglese in di quindi
abbiamo tralasciato questo semplicemente
i nostri processi di selezione sono
stati i processi di selezione di
chiunque
vorrei che fosse quindi i veri
ingredienti del nostro pranzo quali sono
sono umiltà curiosità nei confronti
dell'altro curiosità nei confronti di
culture diverse
accoglienza e aiuto reciproco rispetto
compassione umana e assenza di giudizio
io credo che questa sia l'essenza del
nostro pranzo i regali della nostra
diversità sono che viaggiamo un sacco
gratis che l'india l'africa il sud
america ci sembrano molto più vicini di
un tempo e abbiamo scoperto modi diversi
di vivere nei migliori nei peggiori dei
nostri
e poi siamo più consapevoli del paese
nel quale noi abitiamo perché attraverso
le loro tante domande ai loro occhi
siamo più consapevoli di tante cose a
volte le loro domande sono estremamente
difficili perché ci chiedono della mafia
ci chiedono delle brigate rosse ci
chiedono delle cose che sono abbastanza
scomode per noi delle volte in una
lingua che non è la nostra e trasferire
le sfumature non è certamente facile ma
ci obbligano a a darci a farci delle
domande direttamente a essere molto
chiari in quello che rispondiamo anche
perché in inglese non riusciamo a
girarci intorno insomma
quindi noi insieme ci pensiamo ai ci
viviamo e ci crediamo molto forti e
anche molto competitivi grazie